okay okay first lightnings are go yeah
let me just start the clock you cut them
off here and then okay hi so fast do you
view eyes or GUI that's my cutie graph
I'm Christoph so I want you to look at
this as a Python visualization landscape
and say hey you know what maybe it's
actually a good idea to use this yeah so
why would you think about using it well
yesterday there was a lightning talk
with pie cutie witch pie cutie graph
works on top of idris use it i have
nothing to do with the project
do i have a pull request so you create a
native desktop GUI using pure python it
is fast let me repeat that it is fast
and a pie cutie graph on top of pie
cutie it gives the additional features
like data slicing parameter trees
talking and million other things i found
some of them very useful so how does it
work it's based on qts maybe some people
know what it's event-driven so it gives
it lots of callback functions that
everything is in Python at least
everything you do the framework itself
isn't if you want to look at it install
it my recommendation installed a develop
branch at the last release was two years
ago but there are people working on it
there's commits getting applied all the
time and there are releases apparently
in the works okay it's not one guy doing
it anymore now it's to two other people
so the documentation is unfortunately
quite limited but let's look at the
examples and just add app which is what
they dress I mean one or two people they
can only do so much so basic clotting
this is just the what happens when you
say run you know arrays curves points
whatever here updating plot plots you
can do stuff like zooming in or no
scrolling and it changed something over
there
parameter trees you know something like
this you want to enter values because
you need it to be in
active when well I used it to do
vibration data analysis on machines and
sorry about all the other visualization
stuff but you guys were too slow that's
why I use this so you know change stuff
whatever set up your settings for
example data sizing so let's look at
this well we have here a four
dimensional vampire ray so at the top
here you can go up and down and at the
bottom is what z-axis so XY and of
course here's the fourth axis time so
this is apparently used for MRIs and
stuff actually lots of people use it
even though it's somehow its own thing
don't ask me why
well actually I do I'm telling you doc
widgets that's something I find really
cool so you have this plot and you it's
too small so just double click it and
you know now it's big then you take it
and well push it back here because I
don't know
you can't even code I almost skipped
something I think data slicing dark
widgets all right I said it was fast so
multiple plops so I don't know maps a
flip what happens if we give it a
hundred lines with 500 values per
whatever so 30fps on my CPU that's not
bad so my problem was I actually only
needed six lines but well with twelve
thousand eight hundred values per second
and no caps lock so yeah this dissing
works so well and other stuff but they
don't really care so that's cool which
is why I used it so I've only been using
Python since one and a half years ago
and I did this one year ago so well what
did I do
as a beginner I did something like this
so I can't use the real data but it is
about half an hour of data sampled at
twelve thousand eight hundred samples
per second so that's like 20 million
points and you know you can just look
around zoom in what's this okay well
actually you know let's look at a
different same okay frequency modulated
signal
well the FFT looks a bit weird but okay
amplitude modulated hey there's
something there so you can zoom in
everything actually here I don't know
yeah you can change lots of stuff and
you know just recalculate everything
it's very fast try it out if it's
something you need if not well there's a
million other things you can use so
thanks
[Applause]
[Music]